sad soul man catch me on the bootleg cab
podcast you feel me Church on the Move
man
bootleg capture special guest in here my
guy one of the greatest rappers alive
his name is Absol welcome sir
thank you for having me man it's been a
long time I miss you man miss you too
man I feel like um
I want to say the like the last time I
interviewed you interviewed you was uh
on the back of a bus in Tampa Florida or
Tempe Arizona one of those two places
and it was on the smokers club tour
I don't know man it was a long time ago
but uh with Joey yeah we've had a couple
of like tour bus interviews for sure the
greatest yeah we're just talking about
that too getting back on the road yeah
good times explain to me because you
were kind of breaking down off the mic a
bit yeah
I can't imagine like the high you get
after it's been a while since you've
been on the road but just to create and
put so much you know Blood Sweat and
Tears into your art and then hitting
that stage literally though literally
and then hitting the stage and just
seeing the people sing along seeing the
people react seeing the people come
alive for you what's that like man the
feeling the people
um you know I can't really
yeah we got to get this very clear I'm
not I'm legally blind I'm not blind yeah
you're yeah legally yeah so
um yeah but like I was saying like it's
um
excuse me that's one of the main reasons
why like
we took a while to drop the album like I
said
well so excuse me
Julio anyway um
um you know we was gonna drop in 2020
but you know the pandemic of course and
I wasn't just about to drop an album
just to stream you know I need to go out
and
feel the effect you know for other
people touch the people you know shake
hands and really feel the reception
you know what I'm saying and what like
like I was saying like it's performing
for me you know recording is one thing
like you know right writing is writing
creating is one thing is one is one
craft recording is another craft
performing is a whole nother craft so
like
um like I was telling you it's kinetic
like the performance uh
the performance aspect because like you
know like I said
at least one time when I go on tour
every time it never fails I get dog sick
like I I can't do it and then top calls
like you know are you trying to get this
money or what right right you're gonna
let the people down or what right
you know so you know I suck it up get up
get get on get on stage and as soon as I
get on as soon as I touch the stage I am
healed
no matter what you're going through no
matter what physically physically
wherever I am healed completely
because and I know it's be it's a
spiritual thing it's a it's a kinetic
thing for getting the energy from the
people
that I'm reciprocating it obviously and
as soon as I step off of the stage I'm
back sick
right away right away to the bus to go
to sleep right yeah and so it's like you
know you could call it a high but
I I think it's more it's more spiritual
it's more
it's more personal you know what I'm
saying would you consider yourself to be
a because I think there's a difference
between being a religious person and a
spiritual person yeah what what uh side
of the pendulum do you swing on if any
um I mean there's a you know there's a
there's a balance between the two
because you know I obviously you know
grew up in the Christian church
I am the black Liv Pastor you know what
I'm saying but
um you know I do
you know ask questions I do you know
study theology I'm I'm into it all and
you know all of the messages are you
know relative
in essence you know what I'm saying um
so you know to answer your question I'm
just kind of in between somewhere in
between the two somewhere in between the
two but I mean you know I I you know I I
tell you I'm a Christian right who asks
questions
what do you mean that's your your
Christian who also asked questions yeah
a Christian who asked questions yeah
that's fair there you go yeah I feel
like uh I was kind of like uh more uh
atheist for a long time but once I
started doing a lot of like Heavies like
psychedelics it's just I'm just more
like I don't know now you know yes and
that's and that's but the wisest man
knows he knows
nothing you know what I'm saying and so
it's like
and it's crazy how atheist is such a
that word is just so strong right
atheist that's so such a strong it's a
harsh word if you just say it I should
just say yeah that's crazy people look
at you like you say I'm a Satanist yeah
you might as well tell certain people
here yeah exactly right but yeah but you
know like I said man
do without oil you know yeah I
definitely believe in Alien so I mean
you know I don't even want to go there
my thing is
I ain't got enough time no but if aliens
are real right so if they're real if if
if they oh oh so we're doing that I
think they are okay so yeah do you think
they are I'm not saying if are you
saying that they are I've seen some [ __ ]
oh man but if if we find out yeah aliens
are a [ __ ] thing right doesn't that
poke holes through a lot of the
religions of the world
or no no no because when you do the
research they're they're there
they're there you know to start the
serpent the serpent that was the
uh you know that was the you know like
they were there the whole time we just
didn't look at it through the proper
lens yeah it's just because they're very
they're very poetic you know just and
that's just the you know the whole you
know the Christian Bible they're all
there there's you know
if you if you choose to if you choose to
look at it you choose to dig in yeah
they're they're always there there's
always beings
you know what I'm saying like
unexplainable beings that you know this
this and that you know Nephilim you know
just all kind of have you ever uh
witnessed the UFO
yeah
I'll give you this
UFO means what unidentified flying
object I mean by definition if you if
you it could be a Southwest if you if if
you if you saw it why isn't it why is it
unidentified
yeah I'm just on that you know you know
how long you know what I'm on the kids
I'm trying to play like yeah
I've seen I've had a couple of UFO
sightings I mean let's see this shit's
crazy listen
Strawberry Fields
shout out to The Beatles nothing is real
that is a great song that each room's on
and listen to oh man have you ever have
you ever ate shrooms while listening to
that song Oh man
I've been uh
I've broke through to the other side but
many many times on while listening to
The Beatles well I mean that was a Pink
Floyd reference obviously but yes to the
Beatles also yeah yeah you know who's
the best in my opinion oh if you're
[ __ ] shrooming hard oh
Tame Impala bro wow that's nice
absolutely you're absolutely right and
that's more like
that's more like the vibe that's just
like you know they got a song called Let
It Happen yeah yeah oh my god well yeah
I love tame impossible I was a time I
was uh I was at a Joshua tree with my
wife everybody does it loves to go to
church well [ __ ] you know I guess
it's the LA hipster yeah the tree is the
is the is the Psychedelic it's like the
Psychedelic Walmart it's like the
commercial like like we have to we have
to go to Joshua Tree we have to you know
that's so ill I had that song over two
hours straight though this is the
greatest song I've ever heard in my life
I I can attest to that great [ __ ]
Record Man great entertainment Paula
holla at me man if you ever see this man
I never even knew that Tame Impala was
one dude until like six months ago
I've always thought it was a band it
sounds like a band right like the name
yeah yo tame Impala's headliner
Coachella yeah and then I'm like oh it's
just the dude he's like you know like a
really just talented alien level
musician I guess right he's like oh
that's [ __ ] kind of crazy right right
very talented guy
um yeah what up we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family over at my bookie that's
right with lots going on in basketball
right now Lots going on in the NFL
playoffs are about to start Super Bowl
is coming up so much to gamble on let's
win some money go to my bookie right now
if you sign up for a new account
mybookie.ag
you can gamble from wherever you're at
yes go to my bookie and use the promo
code bootleg when you sign up for that
new account and they will match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
that's free money in your pocket uh that
you can gamble with so if you put a
thousand bucks in your account they're
gonna give you another thousand dollars
to gamble with so go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up with that
new account one more time they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars all right so like maybe
you want to put 200 bucks on the Cowboys
or some [ __ ] to win the Super Bowl
you're gonna lose that money because
[ __ ] the Cowboys but let's say you do
want to put some money on the Cowboys
you sign up you put 200 they give you
another 200. on top of that free money
to gamble with is called the double
deposit bonus and you can only get it by
using the promo code bootleg so go to my
bookie right now sign up for an account
let's get back to the interview yo talk
about this new album man because it
feels like
probably I mean it feels like one
number's personal bodies of work I'm
gonna start off by saying that was such
an excellent segue from you know the
Extraterrestrial to my mom came and
Paula my most personal album yeah I'm so
honored thank you of course man
um this album is uh I mean look man it's
it was highly anticipated I feel like
um
as somebody who's been a fan of you for
the last 10 plus years right
to me this felt like your strongest body
of work and that's saying a lot because
you've had so many of those correct
correct and you know you know I also uh
I also have a bone to pick with you
because I did not make your list but you
know why you're in your defense I know
what you're gonna say I know you know
what I'm gonna say it's a little too
late you know it's late well no no I had
to fully like got it wasn't enough time
no I put the list together right yeah
and then your album dropped on the 21st
right six 16th okay okay
so I did not fully like live with your
album exactly I listened to it on the
plane once exactly but I didn't get to
like live no right exactly so I I I I I
kind of disqualified anything from the
last really from from December no yeah
and I I get that that's yeah that's what
I said you know I'm just you know I'm
just [ __ ] around with you but uh you
know that means a lot coming from you
though that you you know what I'm saying
because I'll tell you this when I do
next year's list I'm gonna just include
the end of December as well and you'll
be on there and let's [ __ ] you know
some some crazy might happen you never
know you never doubt it but uh you know
that uh you know like I said I
appreciate that it was uh
but that's my explanation for sure and
it's truthful and I believe it yeah I
believe it uh and um
excellent list too by the way thanks man
excellent Liz
um yeah man it's it's really not
it's just man like I I went in
you know
my last album was very heavy on the ears
it was very uh dark if you will you know
I just went I felt like I was you know
just going a little too left a little
you know too much Joshua Tree or nothing
wrong with that
you know what I'm saying but um
you know I took I took like a year and a
year and some change off to
you know just you know get back Center
and you know I just kind of wanted to
you know go in you know and challenge
myself what I usually do when I when I
create
you know I have a concept I go in with a
concept because you know I'm old school
I'm all about I just more people did
that yeah I'm all about bodies of work I
grew up reading Source magazine I want
five mic of course so that's my whole
things yeah but what I did this time was
I just literally just
I just went in and worked and and
just let it and let it happen I see
where you're just tied everything
together look at that I can't stop so
um and and the you know
the concept just kind of
created it's created itself you know it
just kind of it was so personal I was
you know I was very open I was very
vulnerable
um
you know I'd like I didn't really I
tried not to listen to Too Much music
like on my own
you know you can't you can't stop the
music though you know right I can't you
know try to minimalize it
exactly yeah that was that was my whole
thing so I wanted it to sound like me
um
I really
um
really really you know leaned on my
producers this time and I didn't I
didn't more so pick beats you know I I
you know I'd let them challenge me like
yeah one of the I think it's like track
three or four I tweeted this uh this
will beat switch up is [ __ ] crazy I
forget the name oh we just talked
Highland days yeah yeah we were just
talking about that that beat switch up
is cool yeah yeah we had to because we
had dropped we had dropped that was like
the appetizer
we had dropped the first version and so
like you know I wanted to do something
you know special for the album like just
you got punch wrap in his house on there
exactly you know what I'm saying so
you know it was a lot of it was it was a
roller coaster but like like I said it
means a lot that you uh
you know you enjoyed it yeah man I mean
I think like being vulnerable is
probably one of the greatest qualities
like the greats can have yeah
um yeah you know I think you know if you
even if you think of someone like hope
who we don't look at it's like the most
vulnerable guy he's had some pretty
vulnerable moments that we don't really
you know think about but right um is it
hard was it because you got really
personal on this album was there ever
like a point in time you're like man I
maybe recorded some [ __ ] and you
question whether or not you like like
it'd come out or you know because when
you share your life like that yeah
there's consequences yeah whether it's
your family or your inner circle or you
know just sit that you don't necessarily
want because I'm sure when you record
yeah it's therapy yeah and then what
comes out is something totally different
right right yeah right I mean there's
there there are those moments but you
know
you gotta you know this ain't for the
faint of heart you know you're gonna
have courage you gotta be brave
you got you know you gotta understand
that
you know well I I understand that you
know my my testimony can can
can help
you know it's we we are just we all just
really want to know that we're not alone
anybody's going through it everybody's
going through something
and you know I just you know when I'm
when I have those
moments where I feel like
it's a bit much man my mom might not
need to hear this
I you know I just remember that you know
is this for you might help a fan I might
help somebody else out yeah you know
what I'm saying and you know it's got to
be like an interesting burden to carry
like because you kind of have throughout
your career talked to fans personally
you've probably been like yo yo save my
life well yeah literally and so when you
literally when you're getting ready to
release music you kind of know like damn
this this can affect someone's power
yeah right like I think artists take
that lightly sometimes yeah for the good
or for the bad right and I don't like I
said like I always say you know like
when people when I meet people when they
say you know man you don't even
understand man you you like you you
saved my life and I
um
I'm very serious adamant about saying no
you saved mine hmm
you know by giving me a voice by by
listening like so
we go hand in hand you know what I'm
saying yeah one hand washes the other
it's a very so you know it's the
reciprocity is very important to me you
know and I'm grateful I appreciate it
all
um what I thought was dope was when you
jumped on uh Russ's Chomp project was it
Chomp two euron Trump yeah was it the
second one drop one or two which one was
it was it 20 21 or 2020
anyway well you're on one of the Chomps
yeah
um and I know Russ has always been like
a huge uh fan of yours anytime I've ever
talked to him he's always brought you up
it's like you know it's my brother the
young Legend man yeah and like it's
funny because like he had shared uh some
old DMS where he was hitting you up yeah
like 2011. yeah like he used to like
harass me on Twitter yeah that was so
cool and now you jumped on his [ __ ] and
then now he's on your [ __ ] like yeah
talk about your relationship with a guy
like Russ who I think is given a lot of
free games a lot of artists out there
yeah doesn't he doesn't just keep the
game behind the lock lock doors right
right I think some people might take his
messaging the wrong way I think he's a
great guy you know I I know I know he
means well I mean he you know he that's
when he just he's just uh
he's just a free spirit for sure at
heart and he just he just means well I
mean he's he's just trying to be of
service
um
but
I just I I think he's just like the
definition of
dedication yeah he's the definition of
dedication and consistency and
you know he's he's really you know he's
very he's very skilled he's very
intuitive
you know what I'm saying like I you know
and he could wrap his ass off nah that's
what I'm saying like he's he's he's
really skilled so you know and that's
like I said man that's that's
the young Legend and like as somebody
like you grew up when he read when he
reached out to me I had like I kept
hearing his name right
and I had and I had heard his records
but I didn't you know put a face to it
or you know
but you know uh he reached out to punch
and punch sent me the record and then I
was like oh oh this is cool like would
you like should I do it he was like oh
yeah I I love his Hustle
so I'm like all right yeah cool so he
gave me his number and then I reached
out to him and then we had to talk and
then he sent me like the old tweets yo
this is crazy so then I did my research
I'm like oh this is this guy oh wow yeah
oh oh for sure so you know yeah shout
out to Russ I should say like coming
from your roots right yeah you used to
work at a record store yes
had a crib in the record store reading
Source magazine as a kid caring about
bodies of work you're a fan first right
you could tell that by how you rap some
of the people you work with right how
much of like keeping your ear to the new
wave of what's going on or discovering
new artists are you still doing
uh because it's tough right it's tough
because it's a lot but you know I
I just kind of look at it as you know if
it hits my desk
you know yeah that's that's how I am
when it hits when if it once it hits my
desk
you know it's something to consider you
know and I just you know have my but but
like I said I'm like
I'm losing my I'm losing my opinion I
found myself becoming a Critic and I
just think that's all
as an artist
as an artist I don't think that's
healthy because you know me being
someone who can you know honestly say
I've I've influenced a lot of great new
artists you know like Russ you know we
don't do it who would tell me that I you
know
I've influenced him I I can't
it's a diff I just found myself becoming
a Critic like who you know like called
like oh that's whack you know this and
that but it's like artist art
and
it's it's open for interpretation it's
it's objective it's it's not for
everybody it's for who it's for
and I mean these are just these are kids
these are these are these are people
you know just trying to make something
of themselves man just trying to trying
to be successful trying to leave their
mark on on the world so
I'm I'm practicing just
you know just being a listener versus a
Critic yeah I can't just at and as an
artist though you know what I'm saying
now see you know somebody like yourself
you know you kind of have that platform
to you know hold those right those
discussions right which is warranted
right we have to have that right because
it is you know it's competitive at the
end of the day it's it is a sport you
know yeah and it's the number one genre
music of the world so it's like exactly
so people are going to have opinions
people are gonna right but I've just
found it as myself as an artist that
could hinder
my my you know I'm worried so much about
how this isn't good for the culture that
I'm not focusing enough on your [ __ ]
exactly that's fair yeah and then you
get bitter and then you you know you
just I think it's funny how like
um throughout our whole life there's
always been
like some version of like the real rap
versus the yeah the commercial [ __ ] yeah
and it just keeps like Reinventing
itself yeah like error by Era yeah so
it's like you know 2017 it was that
SoundCloud Mumble [ __ ] yeah yeah right
and it's like I just feel like there's
always this like
conversation about like oh that's that's
that there's always a genre of a
sub-genre of hip-hop that's like easy to
kind of write off as like hey
but at the end of the day if you can
kind of
understand there's certain places for
everything like if I'm in the club right
I love hearing all this [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying exactly there's a time
and a place where if I'm on a road trip
right
um you know I mean I would love to
listen to Herbert exactly so I'm saying
like and then you look at you know like
the 2017 Mumble rap on Soundcloud these
guys are getting millions of views
they're getting millions of views for a
reason
I mean that just has an example no
you're right you're right they were
getting a lot of views based on
everything but the music though that to
me that was like Peak Instagram antique
okay well then see that opens up a whole
nother there was like Instagram
influencers getting record deals in 27.
right yeah it was you know that's the
whole you know like but you know hey we
got through that we did get through that
I feel like we kind of got through
outside of the uh nft rapper that just
that was signed a Capital Records for
two weeks oh man you saw that guy yeah
the robot right Jesus Christ that was oh
that was
that [ __ ] was crazy I'm like bro like
what is it I'm glad that I was literally
scared
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to uh stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah Bluetooth gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue shoe
right to your [ __ ] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[ __ ] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [ __ ] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[ __ ] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [ __ ]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not gonna perform it's
not it's not going to perform how you'd
like it to but you know how it will
perform if you're on that [ __ ]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [ __ ] Luka
donkic 61 Point [ __ ] performance on
that [ __ ] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview I gotta acts quick though I
was scared have you seen this um this
new uh there's like this new program
that it like will it's like AI generated
have you seen it where you could like
tell it to write you an essay or a song
or whatever and it'll write it within
seconds so you could be like
write a song about
wow my day on the bus and then it'll
just write like a it or I know I know
they have an AI for every for everything
though but I mean that's just it's
[ __ ] sketch that's that's not that's
see there you go let's check this out
man look
you're not what a time to be alive would
you buy a Tesla robot for your house to
like help you around like you know like
maybe like a a butler I would not not a
Tesla one no no I would not I like I
like when I go when I go to stores I
like to
I like to I don't like to self-check out
I like to deal with people when I when I
talk on the phone I ask for the operator
I hit zero over and over and over and
over representative representative
customer service customer operator I
don't I like to deal with people that's
just me I and listen no for sure that's
the most frustrating [ __ ] is when you
call somebody right you know talk to a
human being about something yeah you
could use our self-automated system yeah
like nah I mean and guess what you know
that's the future that's technology we
can't
right can't hide from me can't run from
me but you know that's just me you know
it's [ __ ] to me some of the [ __ ]
they're talking about yeah
how is it we've made all these movies
that are a warning of what happens if we
go down this path too much did nobody
watch these [ __ ] movies and we're
still turning this [ __ ] up like what is
happening like nobody saw a [ __ ]
Terminator I Robot like what the [ __ ] is
going on with these people
you're not getting the neural link chip
no yeah
you think Elon could be alien they said
like Terminator was I think Terminator
was the prequel of the Matrix I think
[ __ ] I didn't hear that yeah the looking
at that uh now I'm gonna say that I try
and watch all of them I had to say that
out loud in mind yeah we'll go ahead
yeah
yeah I think if we're talking about
aliens if anybody is kind of an alien
it's probably Elon Musk oh yeah Elon is
yeah he's a he's an interesting cat yeah
yeah Elon if you're watching this man
yeah just I just I just need one b
just give me one man I just please I rap
really well check out my album wait what
did you say you need 1B what is that a
billion oh a billion okay just just
throw me one man you got you got plenty
just he said he said a lot on my new
album on Twitter check out my new album
man Herbert is out now man it's very
personal you know what I'm saying I put
everything I had into it I just need one
billion man just look out for your boy
man yo when you look back at like early
TDE days I think back to like I think
the first time
I probably met you was
it was probably like 2010 I was living
in Vegas
and uh
Kendrick had a show at a place called
the Forbes Lounge
and uh you opened two Dope Boys was
there doing an expose on you guys shots
shaking those guys
[Music]
um but uh it's just it's just crazy to
see and I remember you guys were the
first guys who like during the mixtape
era was making me buy [ __ ] on iTunes it
was frustrating as [ __ ] man so I got
everybody's [ __ ] Absol I was they're
calling it a mixtape but I gotta [ __ ]
go on iTunes and spend 12 on this
[ __ ] thing right very smart right
obviously right
um but just like to see like what this
whole thing has become
sometimes we like don't realize that
we're in it and we don't sit back and
appreciate where we came from I'm like
exactly exactly because it's like I
don't like I I remember if I as a kid if
I if I could just make 30 grand a year
doing radio you'd have told me I made it
I'd have been happy the rest of my life
correct so I don't ever like go back too
much and think to myself like damn like
how far you came do you ever do you ever
like take the time to appreciate the
journey that has been and how how you
guys are like I've shaped the culture
that's exactly what this album is about
it's about like going it's nostalgic
it's about
getting back to the root root of it like
you know we did more with less let's get
back to the foundation right that's why
it's like simply called Herbert is
simply my name
is simply about that like what it took
to get to this point like and I felt
like
I was
getting too far away from that um you
know I was just becoming this
you know this this this this this
character even you know I was becoming
ab soul right versus
you know this album is for this album is
for the people who will never call me
Absol
um that that I'm still herb I'm still
I'm still a little herb I'm still
Herbert it's for those people and it
just so happens to
Translate
you know you know of course yeah I mean
yeah I mean exactly because you know
it's just about
foreign
your foundation is everything man the
tree grows from the bottom
and if you just if you when you forget
that
and you you know you get too far away
from that without acknowledging that
without
you know appreciating that right you
know you could you know you could you
could lose you could lose yourself in
this man very very easy yeah and I think
it's like sometimes we do ourselves a
disservice by not reflecting and not
yeah maybe once every few months just
sitting back and just
appreciating what you what you got
exactly yeah for sure and it's not it's
not a um
because you could you could you could
you could easily like start what I
should have cutting too
yeah for sure and then and then and then
also looking at your peers and then
being like ah man you know I should have
but you but that's not it it's just
about like man like it's about just just
the journey and just appreciating the
journey and what it took to get here and
you know everybody that was involved in
you know everything that you know it's
just it's you know it's very important
that we
stay connected you know to the to the
bottom yeah
that's that's that's basically what the
album is about it's not it's not that
deep this time right right you know it's
not it's really not that deep this time
it's just really about the last album a
little deeper a little Jesus yeah I took
it to Cairo
it's hieroglyphic you know what I'm
saying but I mean you know yeah it's a
classic you know yeah for sure to me but
I mean you know what what I'm saying
like so this was me just trying to
just get back to self man before before
all of this stuff you know
um can you give me any sort of insight
because I know a lot of people
you know have already gotten over the
fact that the black hippie album allures
is gone came and went you know yeah uh
but how many songs were if any were set
aside for this this detox of a dream
that we all had
it could be zero it could be three I
don't know how many how many like how
many records were like conservatively
like okay the if we do this black hippie
thing this is this is in that folder on
that hard drive well that's what I'm
gonna say that's why I say again we did
more with less
so you know I don't wanna
you know
yeah but [ __ ] why I can't be man I'm I'm
I'm the best rapper out of all the
[ __ ] Can't Rap with me you know
I mean
we do know Q can out golf you though
absolutely that's that's been that's
been proven right yeah he's a uh he's a
savant on that golf course yeah Jesus
Christ does he ever have you like gone
like actually Quincy Woods have you been
golfing with him no not yet yeah he he
said I'd be I'd I'd
with your vision situation I had to
waste time I was gonna say with your
vision situation yeah is you going
golfing the safest thing
I mean I know I know you're not blind
blind but like I mean to say this it's
not a safety issue he just was like bro
you be holding us up
I'm not gonna have you out there we
trying to you know what I mean like he's
like a [ __ ] Pro now yeah he's really
he really does that [ __ ] so that that's
just the whole thing but like you know
I'm sure I get out there just I've never
like been on an actual Golf Course have
you been to Topgolf I went to that's
where I'm you saw me on top so it was
cool topograph is cool but I'm saying I
one day I want to like go on an actual
golf course yeah in the cars have some
beers you know shoot the [ __ ] meet the
meet the rich people
you know shoot this [ __ ] be the ritual
you know what I'm saying that's great
you feel me uh join a country club you
know I want to do the whole thing I want
to do the whole dance man give me a nice
omelette you know those country clubs
are expensive that's what I'm saying man
go give me a 50
omelette you know I feel like uh enjoy
life the only do you ever watch a Curb
Your Enthusiasm I love Kirby it's my
favorite show ever one of my favorite
shows like the only thing I relate to
Country Club [ __ ] is everything that him
and Jeff oh bro because they're always
talking about that episode with the swan
oh just there's a million episodes
man if I get like Larry David's age I'm
gonna join me at Country Club for sure
I'm gonna get wrapped up in a bunch of
old [ __ ] politics with these old
[ __ ] people yeah
it just looks great on this shirt I
can't wait to the next season oh the
last season was amazing when he was
[ __ ] that annoying uh politician lady
bro yeah that was oh my God would you
where would you rank like uh give me
your top five like sitcoms like or
comedies uh I can't I'm just terrible at
the top five things just give me five of
your favorites now no we're not talking
about dramas we're not talking about the
breaking bads of the worlds or The
Sopranos I'm talking about just funny
shows
funny shows man oh my God I can't do
this with you
I seriously can't man because I'll tell
you this like after I watch curb that
made me go back and watch Seinfeld yeah
I was I so I watched Seinfeld first I
never I didn't get it I couldn't
understand I was younger obviously but I
mean I never understood until I saw a
curve my wife curve and then I wouldn't
watch Seinfeld it's [ __ ] brilliant
yeah uh then I watched for some like for
some reason I watched [ __ ] Frasier I
love Frazier Fraser salad Frazier is
funny as [ __ ] which was a spin-off of
Cheers yep and then like you know I'm
just on I've been on that like I just
been on the
like watching the old joints that you
know uh
you know The Sopranos man Sopranos is
Ray Donovan oh Ray Donovan is that I
just I can't do that I can't do the face
but not a lot of people [ __ ] with Ray
Donovan yeah that's Matt looks like Ray
Donovan by the way I think that's just I
think I think it might be racist yeah
you just told me all white people look
the same and and no no I didn't I'm
looking at that right now
Ray Donovan was crazy no but Sopranos
what about did you [ __ ] with the wire of
course the wires I rewatched them during
the pandemic for the first time in like
10 years and I was like it's the go to
me yeah the wire is crazy I got the wire
Breaking Bad Sopranos those are my three
yeah on the funny [ __ ] though it's like
Curb Your Enthusiasm and then just
everything else hey we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at hard Dean that's right
hard Dean Las Vegas the craziest
dispensary in the world the number one
dispensary in the United States let
alone in Las Vegas all right maybe
you're hitting Vegas with your friends
your girlfriends whatever maybe it's a
bachelor party whatever's going on
you're going to go watch the Raiders
suck [ __ ] whatever it is make sure you
pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas tell him I
sent you they got the craziest selection
of Premium cannabis I've ever seen in my
[ __ ] life the pre-rolls the
cartridges the Edibles the flower all
top notch all the best the bud tenders
are so so friendly it smells great it
smells so good inside a Jardine that
they have their own Harding signature
scent candle
see I sniff that and I just think of Las
Vegas and picking up some amazing weed
alright so go follow them right now
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot him a
follow get all the details you need you
can get you some of this fly ass Jardine
merch at hardinglasvegas.com shout out
to our family in Vegas I'm excited too
because coming up we're going to be
doing our very first podcast from Jardin
in Vegas with young gravy oh yeah it's
going down all right let's get back to
the interview yeah The Boondocks I like
I like like new girl oh I mean you know
The Boondocks obviously yeah uh shout
out to my brother new girl shout out to
my brother doe burger man you know Long
Live dough Burger you know I just lost
him we were literally we're literally
Huey and Riley from The Boondocks wow so
you know I had to mention I had to say
that since you said that I like new girl
on uh Netflix new girl's good new girl
that's funny as hell uh [ __ ] um do
you ever watch F is for family the Bill
Burr [ __ ]
he's got to see the cartoon right that
was pretty funny uh Happy Endings yeah
do you watch any stand-up [ __ ] yeah are
you like who's like like what's I want
to see JB smooth so bad live he's so
funny he's [ __ ] hilarious man uh if
you think about like his character it's
like so iconic on TV oh bro yeah bro
that whole when they had that [ __ ]
episode where he was like fixing [ __ ]
for people he was like the handyman but
he really didn't know what the [ __ ] he
was doing about the end of the episode
everything breaks that he fixed yeah
classic [ __ ]
um I always kind of consider you to be
kind of like uh one of the like rap
Jedis yeah you know yeah I think I am
when we talk about Han Solo was he a
Jedi yeah was he I don't know I was he
held a gun no oh okay you're like Luke
Skywalker makes window
I didn't get too deep into Star Wars
yeah overrated franchise don't say that
it's a little overrated don't say that
it's good I'm not saying that
you know Star Wars like Clone Wars the
cartoon series is the best thing that
they ever put out
um but with that being said yeah who's
in the club with you man
in your opinion who's in that Jedi Club
wow
because I hate naming names man I'm with
the guys man and let and let's do this
can we say okay before you start naming
names
then I'm asking you this on the fly so
you might leave some names off I'm gonna
leave some names off
ah man
I have to say you know Kendrick of
course man he's playing you know me me
and Kendrick are killing Ryu you know
what I'm saying I'm I'm Keen he's right
you okay
of course I have to say that I Gotta
Give it to Cole of course uh you know
I I I I have to say Drake but Drake like
is like unfair yeah he's kind of like a
cheat cheat code he's a cheat code but
he doesn't cheat he does it I mean he's
cheated I'm not doing it Drake is Drake
man yeah no Drake's Drake Drake strike
[ __ ] Drake he's Drake for sure I'm
not gonna leave him out you got to Big
Sean killed by the way kill that verse
on your heart yeah went went off uh Joey
Badass of course of course
um jid I love jid I I love chance I love
uh
uh I really love uh Mick Jenkins yo Mick
is fire I guess fire Earl of course uh
Vince of course you know
um Jesus Christ man the guys man there's
a lot it's it's there's a lot of Jedis
out there man I don't wanna
what about this I just got into an
argument with my boy we were arguing
about the two most underrated rappers
ever
and the argument was between black
thought and Sean Price Jesus Christ now
I said Sean price because black thoughts
got the accolades of the roots being on
TV Grammy Etc who do you think is the
most underrated rapper of all time
hey see you're a [ __ ] hip-hop head
cannabis cannabis [ __ ] yeah but it's
understood
yeah I had him on the show like last
year yeah that's that's cannabis is my
[ __ ] he's like the reason but anyway
would you consider it was like a big
influence by one one of the biggest
influence
one of the biggest influences and he
knows this like you know yeah 2000 BC
was I feel like was like bro a lot of
people pass over that project because
and I love to keep leaving Canada I love
cannabis [ __ ] yeah come on N word
number three I battle you on a net I
battle You In the Flesh battery you over
the phone you could call me collect a
battle you full of respect I battle you
over a blank check I battle you with a
gun on my neck I battled you standing
over the toilet with my dick out I
battle you juggling a hand grenade with
the pin out in a stolen car with the fan
number ripped out drinking again in
style doing a 360 spin out
shout out to cannabis yes sir you guys
ever worked together
um
um we yeah I mean he's a peculiar guy
yeah but you know he's but like I said
yeah no for sure no for sure yeah I
respect that's a great answer by the way
this is definitely one of the most
underrated rappers ever yeah but I think
it's like because he's kind of like the
lyrical spiritual Miracle like when
people say that right but they're
talking about like him kind of they're
talking about him but like the one that
makes sense with it but like I think
that he I think cannabis got what he
wanted out of this rap [ __ ] yeah for
real that's fair I think he got exactly
what he wanted out of this so how long
are we gonna have to wait for another
album not long at all okay uh I'm
telling you it only you know
I don't want to blame the panda I don't
want to blame you know I'm to blame no
one else is to blame let's kill them
let's kill the uh
uh let's
not utilize the top and punch or holding
or shelfing us and all of that can we
normalize we do here to hear that a lot
that's cool and they think it's cute
like yeah just let them blame us bro
listen this is the game like we're
really family we don't
we put out we put our product that we
all feel is great because we all
represent each other and that's just how
it is
but if I want if if I if I feel strong
enough about anything I have the
creative control to do it so let's just
set that record straight so the
narrative that
because we hear it it doesn't matter
which artist we could name on the label
if we wait if the out if it's too long
before we get an album the fans always
say it's Punch or it's top exactly no
we're going to get rid of that narrative
here we're going to get rid of that
narrative here please and I'd like to
point out you guys have like quality
control wise probably like when we think
of like Artistic integrity like the
highest of any label in hip-hop we've
ever seen correct and dreamville's right
behind you correct Cole's done a great
job of curating his roster and finding a
great artist but absolutely
um with that like quality it's not
microwavable [ __ ] like nah that's that's
what I'm saying because we all I feel
like
you know luckily
I think we all came in with the same
premise like we all like came in like
you got to understand too like you know
we could work we from like let's not
let's not get it twisted bro like we're
from L.A yeah
we are enemies
like we're not supposed to be friends
none of us
that was our whole premise like we came
in like trying to you know unite unite
and try to you know dead the
you know the
the generational you know curses you
know try to trying to try to end this
you know this the cycle you know that
was we came in with that premise and the
fact just that alone like aside from the
you know the creative aspect that we you
know the chemistry that we have
we came in with that same premise
because we are not supposed to be
friends we are all enemies
politics La politics
yeah if you know if you know you know
hey if if you don't I mean that's that's
cool too but just know like that alone
was powerful enough for you know for all
of us that we were able to be these are
my best friends these are my brothers
these are family to me and
and the fact that it's cool
the fact that it's been it's been
accepted you know there was no I didn't
have to
I didn't have to go argue with you know
with the with the homies about what I'm
doing I didn't have to go every that's
the fact that it's accepted is is
beautiful hey we got to stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at Odd Socks that's right the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ]
world go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off Christmas time is it coming
and let me tell you something their
Black Friday sale if you're watching
this before Black Friday you might be
watching it after Black Friday but if
Black Friday hasn't came yet just like
Cyrus hasn't came yet it's been a while
he's on a drought guess what
oddsocksofficial.com promo code bootleg
20 off plus whatever the [ __ ] else is
going on with their Black Friday sale
and let me tell you they got some new
licenses we got to talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview I do feel like too you
guys have kind of influenced a new
generation of La artist yeah whom
aren't letting politics get in the way
of working together as maybe 10 or 12
years ago that would have been the case
now not to say that that's correct
because that's still that's stupid
correct
happens it happens it is
because it's a real thing and we can't
it's a real thing like it's got I'm just
saying like the new generation like they
work together so much more in L.A and I
yeah I I feel like we
I feel like we set the stage for that to
be possible I can I can honestly say
that with all
you know with the you know with the
utmost respect not trying to be like you
know we started this [ __ ] right you know
we we set the stage for that
you know that
that idea like you know red and blue
made green like yeah like put this we're
brothers like we all fighting the same
fight just happened to be born where we
were born we're born we were born we're
from where we're from we did what we did
you know this happened to this happen
you know what I'm saying my my my homie
might have did this to your homie my
family member might have did this to
your family member but this is us and
the cycle got to stop somewhere
who's the second greatest rapper from
Carson oh
you're number one I'd say well I mean if
I'm number one and we gotta uh you gotta
I mean I gotta go razzcast I was gonna
say Rascals right because nature of the
threat alone is like [ __ ] yeah right
exactly yeah if we're gonna end so you
know so you see the you see the
connection I mean obviously was that
yeah because like I remember one time
rascas walked in I literally did you
know I did threatening nature like on my
last I did that based off nature you
know we've had that talk you know and
his sons are fire oh bro he's got those
Twins and then Coach Contra coach
contrast six yeah like I met them early
because I had you know I had teacher
Moses on my last album too and I didn't
they I don't know if they were rapping
yet but they she bought them there and
they were just like flies on the wall
like I didn't even pay no attention
because I was just a big fan of teacher
and that's when I had met them and then
just to see what they've become is like
they're kind of like yo I feel like uh
they give me remnants of because
remember back in the day man we used to
be a fan of somebody off of a freestyle
we got a hamster yeah you'd be like yo I
got this joke button freestyle yeah or
this uh what was uh the stretch and
bobito [ __ ] freestyle from Big L the
seven Minute Freestyle you know [ __ ]
like that I feel like the coast Contra
[ __ ] is like the new version of that
because like I'm gonna keep it real with
you bro I just said this I don't know I
don't care how anybody feels about this
coast country is like because it's
really the real black hippie
oh cat I I like that actually we could
have switched names
like they should be black hippie and we
should have been close Contra it would
have made more sense they're incredible
they're incredible man yeah though hey
don't add me so new albums before the
next two years you say we get another
album in the next but by 2025 we'll have
another album yes sir okay tour
mid-year summer
spring very soon lining it up as we
speak
very soon stay tuned so new tour coming
obviously uh you have not seen the fans
for a while so be on the lookout for
that wait please show up please come out
we're gonna have a great time I got a
lot of a lot of surprises a lot of
things in store it's gonna be we're
gonna have a great time
um merch is out merch is out merge is
available I think we got the vinyl I
think it still might be some um you know
we you know we made cassettes with the
Walkman the the
limits on the Asian box which is which
is super super dope I don't know like I
said you know my first demo was on
cassette like I come from that like
two questions before you leave one yeah
you brought up the source earlier what's
an album that didn't get five mics that
should have got five mics first one that
comes to your head
I'll start doggy style oh guys I only
got four and a half mics
[ __ ] crazy
I think what's the name Wayne Uh the I
don't think the Carter the first one the
first one okay they slided him but yeah
Birdman junior was my [ __ ] Jesus Christ
I miss my dogs come on oh man yeah I
think they sliding wind on the Carter um
I think they had to rewrite uh the
blueprint
I don't think they gave the blueprint
five mics the first time I think they
had to they didn't get Reasonable Doubt
five mics yeah they didn't get
reasonable five months they didn't give
uh yeah but they they went back and gave
the blueprint five I remember that
though I don't think 36 Chambers got
five mics Jesus Christ you know
something yeah so I mean I come from
that area like to where it's like it
mattered yeah it mattered yeah that like
seriously the last thing tell me about
the craziest psychedelic trip you've
ever been on
we will leave with a good trip story
or a bad trip Meek uh
I wish I could tell you who bought us
the shrooms that would be so [ __ ]
crazy but I won't out of respect I'll
tell you off camera okay uh
random famous person bought you shrooms
it'll be so it'll be so crazy uh Kim
Kardashian bought you shrooms right
[Laughter]
yeah shout out to Kim you know what I'm
saying holla at me uh
uh with all due respect that was that
was nice I mean she's single man nah not
even that not just I just love Kim she's
just she's just dope Kim is just dope
she is I didn't even mean it only I
didn't even mean it for sure she's just
dope uh what's her name um
the EQ dish rooms together for the first
time and we were literally telepathic
like literally like you guys were
[ __ ] on the same wavelength we were
bugging the [ __ ] out and I was laying
down on the ground on on my head you can
ask me this I swear I will not lie I'm
laying on the ground like like almost
like in the fetal right
and then
he asked me in his head he said bro are
we mind bouncing right now in his head
and I said yes we are bro stop you're
tripping me the [ __ ] out and this is a
true story that's my that's my illest
psychedelic experience and you can ask
him that's amazing it really happened
and then we went on to do an excellent
show oh you guys did that before a show
yes sir kudos to you was that like the
best show ever
I can't remember but I have done I have
done uh one excellent on my last tour
off of off of the uh yeah see the thing
is yeah but look but before I okay go
ahead before I continue
be careful guys you have to be careful
please be careful
um micro dose first like like listen
just just
psychedelics are mind-altering drugs
substance just be careful you got to be
careful with anything you do with
anything that you do please be careful I
just want to be I I need to say that
because I've kind of been
you've been on the far I've been I'm the
third eye guy you've gotten to the edge
of the cliff
yeah Dark Side of the Moon I'm I'm and
I'm kind of I kind of represent that for
sure I mean of course right which is not
which I own I'm not I'm not saying that
but I just really want everyone to hear
from me you got to be careful be careful
you gotta be around the right people you
gotta be in the right environment be in
the right environment be safe and and if
you're gonna do DMT be really in the
right environment do it with intent yeah
that's not these aren't
you don't do sites to get high you do it
with intent you do it with intent to
to to experience to learn to to to gain
to get a message to expand to ascend
just I just want to make that clear like
we're not we're not it's important yeah
it's important we're not doing it too
yeah because it's not get high you do it
for for therapeutic Therapeutics for
self-discovery self-discovery for those
that's I just want to make that clear
it's not like some [ __ ] you do and go to
the club you've never condone that
exactly that I just want to make that
clear just coming from me because I've
you know been kind of like a you gotta
have a lot of respect for that and what
it can do for you right you know people
come up to me like you know I want to
bring me hey man eat this [ __ ] let's
trip off
it's not that kind of party I respect it
man well listen Herbert is out it's a
great body of work have fun though have
fun yeah yeah I mean that's just a you
know a nice that comes along with it
uh albums out man go support it I
appreciate the time brother appreciate
you so my guys yes sir sir fire